الله تعالى يا ايها الناس انا خلقناكم من
ذكر وانثى وجعلناكم شعوبا وقبائل لتعارفوا
ان اكرمكم عند الله اتقاكم ان الله عليم
خبير
قوله تعالى يا ايها الناس
فهذا النداء وفي الراجح
الى
بني ادم
وقد يتضمن هذا الجن
والجن
منهم المؤمن
وغير المؤمن ومنهم الذكر والانثى
وهم شعوب وقبائل مثل بني ادم
والعلماء
اختلفوا في
ادخال الجن
في النداء وفي مسمى الناس الناس
البشر نعم هذا يختص بالانسان البشر يختص
ببني ادم
كذلك
بنو ادم واضح انه هذا مختص
باولاد وذريه ادم عليه السلام
وكاد ان يتفق العلماء
على انه ما من نبيا بعد خلق ادم الا ومن
ذريه ادم عليه السلام ما في انبياء من
الجن بعد خلق ادم
الله عز وجل
ذكر ان نوحا عليه السلام
وابراهيم
الله عز وجل جعل
النبوه والكتاب في ذريتهما
ليس من ذريه ابراهيم ولا ذريه نوح
احد من الجن فيما نعلم
ونوح عليه السلام هو اول البشر ولذلك يسمى
ويقال لابراهيم عليه السلام ابو الانبياء
ابو الانبياء من قول الله تعالى وجعلنا في
ذريته النبوه والكتاب فما من نبيا يبعث
بعد ابراهيم الا
نسبه
يعود على ابراهيم عليه السلام وكذلك
الكتاب يعني الوحي والنبوه جعلهم الله
سبحانه وتعالى في ذريه ابراهيم وفي سوره
الحديد في ذريه نوح وابراهيم عليهما
الصلاه والسلام
فيا ايها الناس
الذي عليه جمهور العلماء انه
يكون لبني ادم
والجن
ملحقون
في عموم وشمول العله هذا قول
قول اخر
ان يا ايها الناس
الجن داخلون في مسمى الناس وهذا قول عليه
اقل جماعه من اهل العلم لكنه قول معتبر
وعلى كل حال فالايه
في عله
الخلق
في هذه الصفه لماذا لم يتحد الخلق او يتحد
الانسان الناس كلهم يكونوا مخلوقون يكونوا
مخلوقين في نفس اللحظه في نفس المكان في
نفس الظروف ثم يبتليهم الله سبحانه وتعالى
بنفس الابتلاء فمن اطاع دخل الجنه ومن عصى
دخل النار ليس هذا ما جعله الله سبحانه
وتعالى بل خلق الله عز وجل الناس بظروف
مختلفه
وخلق الناس من
من
امكنه مختلفه في ازمنه مختلفه
وجعل
بعضنا ذريه لبعض
وجعلنا خلفاء في الارض
يخلف بعضنا بعضا
فجعل بيننا
النسب والصهر سبحانه وتعالى لماذا يقول
تعالى يا ايها الناس انا خلقناكم من ذكر
وانثى فقوله تعالى انا خلقناكم
فهذا يدل على اتحاد اتحاد الخالق
اتحاد المسبب سبحانه وتعالى في الاصل
وكل انسان
وما منا من احد من الناس
الا وقد شاءه الله سبحانه وتعالى
بمشيئته ولحكمته
هذا العالم جاءه الله وهذا الجاهل شاء
الله وهذا الابيض شاءه الله وهذا الاسود
شاء الله وهكذا كل واحد منا
بمشيئه الله وبخلق الله سبحانه وتعالى
وهذا يدل على اتحادنا في الخالق قال من
ذكر وانثى ان هذا الخلق كان عن طريق
التناسل وكان عن طريق
اجتماع الذكر واجتماع الانثى
الذكر لم يستطع ان
يتناسى وحده والانثى لم تستطع ان تتناسى
لوحدها بل باجتماعهما
حصل هذا التناسل وهي من غايات الخلق ومما
اراد الله سبحانه وتعالى
فليس
باحد على احد فضل
من هذه الناحيه كل واحد منا
فيه هذه الصفه
خلقه الله سبحانه وتعالى
خلقه من ذكر وانثى صح ولا لا فش منه احد
الا وهذا الوصف ينطبق عليه اذا كيف انا
اقول او اجد او ارى ان نفسي خيرا من نفس
غيري وهذه الصفات منطبقه على
على غير من الناس زيه ما فيش اي فرق اي
انسان
مهما كان هذا الانسان
فانه يستطيع ان يقول ان الله خلقني من ذكر
وانثى وهذا الوصف ينطبق وصحيح
يؤخذ اشرف الناس وهذا الكلام صحيح اشرف
الناس في في
يعني في ظن الناس في قول الناس وتاخذ اوضع
الناس في ظن الناس فصحيح ينطبق عليه هذا
الوصف خلقه الله من ذكر وانثى
اذا هذا معنى قولي النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم ليس
لعربي
فضل على اعجمي ولا لاعجمي فضل على عربي
ولا لاحم ولا لي ابيض على اسود ولا لي
اسود على ابيض
كلكم من تراب
كلكم من اتم وادم من تراب هكذا جاء في
الحديث عند الترمذي باسناد صحيح
فالكل مخلوق
من ادم عليه السلام يعود نسبه الى ادم اذا
الانساب وحدها لا تكفي في
تفضيل الناس افراد الناس وهذا في فرق بين
التفضيل بين الافراد والتفضيل بين
بين الاجناس يعني مثلا لو قال
احدنا
الرجال او الرجل خير من المراه
هذا لا يعني ان كل رجل
خير من كل امراه هذا غلط
كلام لا يستقيم لا يصح
ولكن المقصود بمثل هذه العباره حينما
نسمعها من العلماء مثلا
ان جنس الرجل من ناحيه الجنس
اصل الوضع جنس الرجل اكمل من جنس المراه
وضع المراه لكن ليس هذا على الافراد وانما
هذا جماعه بشكل اجمالي لو تقول مثلا
الانسان خير من الجن هل يعني هذا ان كل
انسان خير من كل جن لا
غير صحيح
تم رجال من الجن خير من عشرات او مئات او
ملء الارض من بعض الانس والعكس صحيح صح
ولا لا اذا هذا فرق
بين هذا وهذا ثم اشياء يقصد بها
على الافراد مثل الانبياء خير من سائر
الناس صحيح
كل نبي خير من كل واحد ليس بنبي هذا كلام
صحيح
ماشي
لكن لما تسمع في لغه العلماء وتسمع
العلماء يقولون النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
بعث في خير الناس
ماشي تقرا عباره
العرب
كانوا خير الناس او مثلا مدح النبي صلى
الله عليه وسلم لبعض
المناطق او بعض الناس فيقول مثلا
الايمان يمان
والحكمه يمانيه يمدح اهل اليمن
او مثلا يذم بعض الجهات يسال وعراقنا
فيقول
منها يطلع قرن الشيطان ومنها الفتن هل
يعني هذا الكلام انه كل يمني خير من كل
واحد ليس بيمني هذا كلام باطل لا يقول به
احد
ماشي او تقول مثلا النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم مدح اليمنيين
وذم هنا فتره من العراق هل هذا شامل لكل
زمن
ليس شاملا لكل زمن
هذا شامل للزمن الذي كان فيه رسول الله
صلى الله عليه وسلم وقد
تنتقل
وينتقل الفقه والايمان الى غير من البلدان
كما كان في عصر النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
الحديث في
المدينه ثم انتقل الى مكه ثم انتقل الى
العراق ثم انتقل الى ما وراء النهر وهكذا
في فترات والفقه نفس الشيء
طيب احمد بن حنبل
رحمه الله من العراق
ماذا نقول يعني
لا نقبل عنه لان النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
ذم هذا
ذم المشرق
فهم شديد لا يقول بي احد من العلماء
كذلك النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم يمدح بعض
البيوت نقول خير الانصار
خير بيوت الانصار بنو النجار
هل يعني انه كل واحد من بني النجار خير من
كل واحد ليس من بني النجار هل هذا هو
المقصود لا اذا قلنا مثلا
المهاجرون خير من الانصار هل يعني انه كل
مهاجر خير من كل انصاري مهما كانت درجاته
هذا الانصار ومهما كانت درجات هذا المهاجر
فالمهاجر دائما خير من الانصاري ليس صحيحا
هذا غير صحيح فاذا قلنا مثلا قريش
خير قبائل العرب ماشي
الله عز وجل يقول لقد جاءكم رسول من
انفاسكم
قراءه يعني من انفسكم قراءه من انفسكم
ماشي من انفاسكم يعني نسبا
من انفسكم يعني من انفس
قبائلكم من انفاسكم هل معنى ذلك انه كل
قرشي خير من كل واحد ليس بقرشي واذا قلنا
مثلا العرب خير من العجم معناه ان كل عربي
خير من كل عجمي هذا كلام غير صحيح وغير
مراد ولم يرده احد على الافراد
فان الانسان من بطا به عمله لم يسرع به
نسبه
لكن جماعات ككل ممكن كل هذه الجماعه
متقدمه على هذه في الامور التاليه
جماعه متقدمين على التاليين في الفقه
وجماعه متقدمين في
التاريخ وجماعه متقدمين في البناء وجماعه
متقدمين على وهكذا الناس على حسب ما وهبهم
الله سبحانه وتعالى
بعض الناس
يظن مثلا ان الاسلام لا يفهمه الا العرب
العرب هم الذين يفهمون الاسلام غير العرب
ما يفهمون الاسلام هذا كلام
غلط الاصل انه العرب انزل القران في لغتهم
هذا يدل على اختيار لغه العرب صح ولا لا
فهل نقول ان اللغه العربيه مثلها مثل اي
لغه لا في فضل فضل اللغه العربيه لماذا
لان اللغه العربيه اختارها الله سبحانه
وتعالى لهذه الرساله لكن هذا لا يعني ان
كل من نطق بالعربيه
فانه افصح فكرا وقولا من الذي ينطق في لغه
غير العرب غير صحيح
لما عاجم
لا ينطقون بالعربيه لكن في لغتهم هم افصح
بكثير وانقى فكرا بكثير من بعض العرب صح
ولا لا والعكس صحيح
لكن اذا قلنا اللغه العربيه خير اللغات
هذا كلام صحيح
هذا كلام صحيح او اذا قلنا مثلا الفطره
العربيه كانت او مثلا بعض القيم العربيه
صحيح الان ساب العربيه جميل لكن على مستوى
الافراد لا غلط هذا خطا
وبعض الناس يفهم هذا الفهم الخاطئ ولا
يفهم الفرق بين تفضيل
التفضيل بين الجنس والتفضيل بين الافراد
فاذا قرا مثلا لاحد العلماء يقول الرجال
الرجل خير من المراه هكذا يقرا هيك
فهو يذهب ذهنه الى ايش
الافراد
يعني
هو رجل خير من كل امراه وهذا كلام لا يقول
به احد
بل المقصود الجنس الالف واللام هنا الرجل
هذا للجنس
كيف تعرف الجنس تحط كلمه جنس بدل الالف
واللام تقول جنس الرجل خير من جنس المراه
يعني في اصل كمال الخلقه
عنده لان وصف الرجوله وصف زائد على وصف
الانوثه الرجل يستطيع يفعل اشياء
والمراه فيها نقص وهذا النقص يجبر لكن ليس
هذا في كل شيء وليس هذا على سبيل الاطلاق
وليس هذا على سبيل الافراد هذا غلط
بل ثم نساء خير من
مئات او الوف الرجال
وكذلك
والعكس صحيح يعني مثلا هل من الانصاريات
من نساء الانصار هل منهن
امراه كانت خير من
رجال من المهاجرين في عهد الرسول صلى الله
عليه وسلم ايش الجواب الجواب نعم
كبار الانصار الانصاريات اللي امن في اول
وهل وكان في جميع ما كان فيه النبي صلى
الله عليه وسلم وشارك في جميع هذه التضحيه
خير من عشرات ممن امن بعد الفتح
صح ولا لا لكن هذه المراه الانصاريه عمرها
بتكون
امامه الصلاه
ما بتكون امامه الصلاه
للرجال هل تكون خطيبه
تخطب الناس يوم الجمعه بدلا من بعض الرجال
لا لماذا لان الله سبحانه وتعالى اختص
لبعض الاشياء
جنسا معينا هذا للرجال وهذا للنساء
واما فيه
النفس بان هذه نفس خلقها الله
شاء الله من ذكر وانثى هذا الوصف ينطبق
على الرجال والنساء ولا لا ينطبق على
الرجال والنساء هل هذا الواصف ينطبق على
العرب والعجمي ينطبق هل هذا ينطبق على
الانس والجن ينطبق ينطبق على الصحابي وغير
الصحابي ينطبق
قوله تعالى ان اكرمكم عند الله اتقاكم في
هذا هذا الاصل في الافراد لا
فالافراد الذي يجعل فردا من الناس يفضل
فردا التقوى
ايش هو التقوى
الايمان والعمل الصالح
الله عز وجل يقول
الا انه اولياء الله لا خوف عليهم ولا هم
يحزنون الذين امنوا وكانوا يتقون
فالمتقون هم الذين يكونون
باوامر الله يجتنو يجتنبونه محارم الله
سبحانه وتعالى طاعه لله
واخلاص ومتابعه
فهؤلاء بين الاثنين من الذي يكون الفاضل
ومن الذي يكون المفضول الفاضل
اكثاره اكثرهما تقوى
والمفضول اقلهما تقوى ان اكرمكم عند الله
ماشي هذه مساله انا اذكرها الحقيقه كثير
من الناس يختلط عليهم هذا الامر اختلط
عليهم هذا
المادح يجد في بعض الاماكن
ان الله عز وجل يقول
ان اكرامكم عند الله اتقاكم وبعدين يجد
فيه
بعض
يعني يجد ما فيه ذم للتفاخر بالنسب ثم يجد
ما يشبه التفاخر بالنسب عند الرسول صلى
الله عليه وسلم يقول بعثت من خير بيوت
الكذا بعثت من خير بيوت
قريش مثلا غير بيوت مكه هذا صحيح
جماعه
بني هاشم
ماشي
لو قلنا احنا بنفاضل بين القبائل
نقول بني هاشم خير قبائل قريش لكن هل يعني
هذا انه كل فرد من افراد بني هاشم خير من
كل فرد من افراد من ليس من بني هاشم لا لا
اراد هذا النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم ولا
العلماء الذين يقولون هذا
لكن هل في فرق نعم
لانه كما ان الناس الافراد
يقاسون باعمالهم
كذلك الجماعات تقاس باعمالهم صح ولا لا
يعني نقول
من ناحيه هذه القبيله لها السبق في كذا
وكذا وكذا فهذا له فضل لذلك
المهاجرون خير من الانصار هذا على سبيل
للجنس ولا للافراد على سبيل الجنس ولا
الافراد على سبيل الجنس جنس المهاجر خير
من جنس الانصاري
ولا يعني ذلك انه كل انصاري خير من كل خير
كل مهاجر خير من كل انصاري
كذلك اذا قلنا مثلا
الصحابه خير ممن بعدهم
صحابه خير
من
التابعين مثلا
هل هذا يعني ان كل صحابي خير من كل تابعي
هذه مساله اختلف فيها العلماء
بعضهم قال نعم
لان وصف الصحبه لا تدرك
وبعضهم قال
لا يعني مثلا صحيح من ناحيه الصحبه
لا يمكن التابعي ان يدرك
الصحابي في الصحبه
لكن في العلم والعمل الصالح والتقوى وحمل
اعباء الدين
هل نقول مثلا عمر ابن عبد العزيز
هذا الصحابي الذي دخل المسجد
ولا غفر الله الا لي ولمحمد وبعدين اخذ
بول في المسجد يتبول
والنبي صلى الله عليه وسلم يقول لا تزرم
هذا خير من عمر بن عبد العزيز لانه هذا
صحابي وهذا مش صحابي هل هذا الكلام صحيح
قول ضعيف صعب جدا ان يقال هذا
لكن العلماء رحمهم الله
فان ادبهم شديد خاصه مع الصحبه والصحابه
فانهم قد يقولون هذا لكن لا يصرحون انه
نعم جنس الصحابي خير من جنس غير الصحابي
لكن ثم افراد غير صحابه خير من بعض
الصحابه هذا الكلام قد يتخذ وسيله
لمن لا يفهم ولمن يريد ان يقول
على الله ما لم ينزل به سلطانا من الذين
يريدون ان يغضوا من قدر الصحابه
لا يجعل كلامه هكذا ونفس الشيء كما ان بعض
الناس فهم من له عنصريه نوع من العنصريه
او نوع من النزعه
العنصريه فيقول مثلا انظر العلماء يقولون
انه خير القبائل كذا والقبيله هذه خير من
هذه والعرب خير من كذا وهذا الكلام
استغله بعض
المغرضين
للتقول على العلماء ما لم يقولوا
نحن لا نختلف ان بعض الجماعات خير من بعض
الجماعات لكن هذه الايه في الافراد
ليس ثمه فرد من الناس خير من فرد من الناس
من اجل لونه ولا من اجل لغته ولا من اجل
كونوا ذكر او انثى ليس هذا الكلام
نعم
لا يفضل لا يقول هذا الرجل خير من هذه
المراه دون ان نطلع على العمل لا ان
اكرمكم عند الله اتقاكم صح ولا لا ولا
نقول هذا الاسود خير من هذا الابيض ولا
العكس هذا الابيض خير من هذا الاسود لماذا
لمجرد هذه الخصله هذا كلام غير صحيح هذا
كلام جاهلي
ان اكرمكم عند الله اتقاكم
وكذلك لا نقول مثلا
يعني مثلا انظر الى هذه الكلمه
الفقه يمان والحكمه يمانيه ماشي هذه
الكلمه
جيد هذه الكلمه قال النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم
هل احد من الائمه الاربعه من اليمن
بواب لا طب ليش وكان المفروض هذول كلهم
يكونوا من اليمن
الجواب ليس هذا هو المراد من الروايه اصلا
مراد من الروايه
انا
طبع اهل اليمن في ذاك الزمان في ذاك
المكان كان اقرب الى الفقه واقرب الى رقه
القلب والقروء والقرب من الايمان هذا
معناه
ليس معناه انه مخلوق افقه من غيره فقط
عشان دمه في ماده يعني مش موجوده في
الدماء الاخرى هذا الكلام غير صحيح لا
يريده النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم ولا غيره
ممن قال
كذلك العلماء اختلفوا هل هذه الروايه في
تفضيل اهل اليمن الى يوم الدين ام هو فقط
في زمنه اختلاف اختلف العلماء
نووي رحمه الله في المنهاج في شرح مسلم
يقول لا هذه متنقله
هذا الفقه وهذا الايمان يتنقل على حسب
الزمن لكن في وقته كان عند اهل اليمن
على كل حال هذه الاشياء وين ما شفت في كتب
العلم في حديث الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم
تجد ان الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم يقول
بعثت في خير الناس بعثت من خير القبائل
بعثت من خير البيوت
او يقول مثلا يمدح دار من دور الانصار على
الدور الاخرى يقول خير بيوت الانصار
بنو النجار ثم بنو عبد الاشهل ثم حديث في
البخاري ماشي هل يعني انه كل واحد من بني
النجار خير من كل واحد من بنى
ما فاهم هذا الصحابه اصلا
وكذلك اذا قرات الرجل خير من المراه هذه
ان جاءت اللفظه مفرده الرجل خير من المراه
المقصود به ايش
الجنس
جنس الرجل خير من جنس المراه مثل ما انا
اقول مثلا
ايهما افضل
الذي
هو ضرير البصر ولا الذي هو يبصر ايهما
افضل
اذا قلت المبصر خير من الضرير هذا كلام
صحيح
يعني الذي يبصر عنده هذه الحاسه خير من
الذي لا يبصر كلام صحيح ولا لا صحيح لكن
هل معنى ذلك انه كل مبصر خير من كل ضيق لا
وثم رجال
لا
يبصرون ولكن الله عز وجل
جعل لهم بصيره مما جعلهم خير بكثير من
بعض الذين
يبصرون وهكذا والعكس صحيح
ماشي
فرق بين التفاضل والتفضيل بين الاجناس
بين الافراد هذه الايه في ايش الافراد
وهذه الايه
في الاجناس من ناحيه انه كلنا بني ادم
كلنا انسان
واكرمكم عند الله اتقاكم هذه القبيله لا
تكون خير من هذه القبيله وهذه الامور التي
كانت في الجاهليه انتهت وانقطعت الان
بالتقوى
فقوله تعالى
يا ايها الناس انا خلقناكم من ذكر وانثى
وجعلناكم شعوبا وقبائل لتعارفوا من اجل ان
يعرف
بعضكم بعضا ان اكرمكم عند الله اتقاكم هذا
هو الميزان
فكل ما كان في الجاهليه من
تفضيل الافراد على الافراد
بالجنس او باللغه او بالبشره فهذه انت
هذا من امر الجاهليه
وانما الذي
يفضل الله سبحانه وتعالى به بين الاثنين
هو التقوى
ان التقوى هو المعيار
قال تعالى
ان الله
قال تعالى ان الله عليم خبير وياتي بقيه
الكلام غدا ان شاء الله الله اعلم وصلى
الله وسلم على نبينا